he didn't believe me when i said it was
really loud to do this
[Music]
hey peter
welcome to corridor digital so i saw a
lot of comments about sky drawing which
is where you start up here and you
go down like that
it's actually the easiest way for me to
aim it's also bad form because it's
technically unsafe you're pointing your
arrow up really high save the birds
right danger for clouds so i'm trying to
get better at the like correct
way to draw the one benefit about doing
it like that we just look down the bow
that you aim while you draw back so that
you release right away and not be
holding a shaky bow while i try to
stabilize it
i think the r2 challenge is going to be
you have five arrows and there's five
red circles
and see how many of those red circles
you can hit with your five arrows grand
tournament will be held upon release of
our next video our next quarter video
not our next time
almost missed
so as you can see
studio five is under construction in
studio four we thought it was getting a
little hot in there as well we wanted to
do some
installation
we wanted to do some insulation
ourselves and so the question is when we
did this ceiling in here this whole
studio was full of dust so what do we do
we got to move all of our stuff over
here we got to move all of our stuff
over here for a few weeks you know
honestly i don't think it'll be that bad
but i say that now so so cj your problem
is is unlike us yeah you guys didn't get
desks that roll i know it would've been
far easier if you guys just had to roll
everything yeah i mean the biggest
problem is ren and carmichael are both
still working off of doors
so
seal off the camera room we're going to
seal off the back we're going to have to
move all the wardrobe
move everything out of the upstairs
kitchen because it's all going to get
covered in dust
[Music]
what happens now t-bag them
one of us one of us
one of us one of us one of us one of us
one of us
do i want to go to china i mean yeah my
good friends and aperture
i want oh cooler what's in this cooler
[Music]
120 singles
gold mount
look at how big the led is you've never
seen the custom led light i made it's
better than all the leds any led light
you've ever seen off a battery you can
light up the whole street i'm assuming
that's the same light so i go this is a
different box i hope this is dishes
please be a dish it's really heavy
and then another light storm
oh sick cool wow so many light storms
now
[Music]
but
it'll be a combination of like moving it
down
scaling it up a little bit also